good evening several sex abuse victims
are now suing a former teacher and the
Clark County School District alleging
administrators tried covering up that
abuse thanks for joining us here at six
o'clock I'm Denise Feltes and I'm Brian
Loftus the former teacher sentenced to
prison in 2020 for that crime 80's now
reporter Joshua peguero joining us now
to talk about this lawsuit Denise Brian
in this 29-page lawsuit there are
several claims against the district one
of the alleges when a student came
forward to report the wrestling coaches
abuse staff failed to investigate it
law enforcement arrested Jonathan Cronin
in 2019 for inappropriately touching
multiple students at Sierra Vista High
School three of the victims filed a
lawsuit claiming he sexually abused them
because they were disabled it states he
routinely subjected the three to sexual
molestation harassment and assault which
included sexual physical and emotional
Cronin was arrested during a month-long
staying called operation Silver Star
where more than 20 law enforcement
agencies joined forces to arrest
fugitives as we speak there are people
that are out there that are being
actively pursued by the marshals and my
word to them if you know that you're
wanted turn yourself in
simply walk down and turn yourself in
because sooner or later as was talked
about by the U.S attorney we will find
you in 2020 Cronin was sentenced to a
minimum of three years in prison victims
allege the principal and assistant
principal at the time failed to comply
with state laws and District policies on
promptly reporting the abuse they also
accused these administrators of
concealing this information furthermore
the victims State the investigation into
Cronin was only initiated at the Metro
inquired about one of the students's
allegations now the victims didn't list
a specific dollar amount they're seeking
in their lawsuit attorneys representing
the victim's declined speaking on camera
Brian